[Music]
taking a
little walk with my
about a week into my broken rib trying
to
slowly heal it
listening to the biblical series at the
end of my big synthesis
it's very interesting how i'm
recognizing
more and more of jordan peterson's role
as a
major intellectual father of mine
and many other people around the world
and how
interestingly enough many of the ideas
that
i thought were really profound that i
was coming up with
in 2018 after i had interviewed him
i didn't even know that he was fluent in
but then i realized
that some of the main
profound abstractions in my synthesis
that i focused on are literally ones
that he has also
been hyper focused on and this is in
2020
this is in october 2020 which is really
interesting
and
that kind of a realization of
triangulation
and of what really happened in february
2018 when i landed that interview with
him
it didn't really resonate so much then
that
what was happening was extremely divine
but i understand now more than ever that
one of my main roles is to
walk in the footsteps after jordan
peterson
in helping our world come up with
a metaphysical synthesis and orientation
for people to help them pursue their
north stars
to help them find meaning and be
motivated
and be morally aligned to the highest
possible good
and it's super interesting that it's all
starting to come together right at the
time of
publication of my first book high level
perception
so thank you everybody
and thank you jordan peterson we love
you very much
hope to see you back on the scene soon
i'm really excited for the next times
that we sit down together to talk big
love